Nếu mà bà thân năm 2018, một nữ suốt cách bị sáo tụi đã trụ vọng sâu tên
ở khi trời sĩ đù vách đã tại khu dụi thác mà đi mua nhìn tư sinh chung quốc.
Mình yên bà đầu được sất định là sâu dây an toàn bị đức ngày khi nả nhân dởi
bị phóng ở độ cao hàng chăm mét. Theo video hiện chương, nát nhân linh tục cạnh báo
thích bị bỏ hộ chưa được thách chất trước khi bị in vinh đầy ra hỏi vị trí an toàn.
Này xo đó, zay cá bị đức hiện khu dựa xuống vực vụ việc được sất định có giấu hiệu
phòng quy định an toàn. Há bữa gí plài dí truyền thả được tăng trình dây cáp,
xin đu vách đã tự hành thông li có lắc, mười trời được chào vào dây cáp,
sâu đó, hệ thống sẽ đy hóc thả tự sốt từ bệ phóng định người trời văn giá khu chương
theo hình vòng cùng. Giờ trước đã đing chỉ hoàn động khu dụi đến nè người tháng 5 để phục vụ điều tra,
đồng thời làm gió chỉ việc của đơn vị vẫn hành là trong trình ect.com.